nice hey you still have time to talk
about Paul no I just uh opening up to
different people but yeah we're still
talking about Paul why why why do you
guys uh not trust Paul yeah as a former
Christian I used to think that Paul was
an
apostle but I saw I saw evidence within
the New Testament that shows that this
wasn't it okay so what makes someone an
actual true Apostle and what makes
somebody oh let's do this what's what
makes somebody a false Apostle is that
is the New Testament a criteria by which
somebody is a true Apostle and a false
Apostle it doesn't give criteria for
false Apostles it's it gives the
criteria for a true Apostle so if you
claim to be an apostle and you don't
meet the criteria then by default you're
not an apostle got it so it does give a
criteria so for who is an apostle yeah
right all right so what's one criteria
of being an apostle um that Paul doesn't
meet you had to be with Jesus in his
Earthly Ministry got it so to be with
Jesus in his Earthly Ministry is what
makes you an apostle a true Apostle of
God correct acts one all right I got you
um and you're a Muslim now you said yes
all right so here's the question was
Muhammad with Jesus in his Earthly
Ministry no so then that means that
Muhammad is not a true Apostle of God
right
not an apostle well I me a prophet of
God but not an apostle yeah there's
there's Hadith and stuff that refers to
Muhammad as as Allah's Apostle okay are
those Hadith um authentic of
course okay if you say they're authentic
um well Apostle I'm separating apostle
from Prophet even even Paul says
Apostles and Prophets are
different well that's fine and all but
remember
to to um be a true a AP of God and look
I'm G put on the screen for you s bukari
um right here it says narrated jabir B
Abdullah a betterin gave pledge of
allegiance to Allah's Apostle for Islam
right so talking about Muhammad right it
says it all over and over again there's
a bunch of Hadith that actually say this
you know calls him Allah's
Apostle so because he didn't actually
Walk With Jesus in his Earthly Ministry
then that means that Muhammad's a false
Apostle he's not a true Apostle right
yeah I guess yeah with that logic yeah
then we gotta throw Muhammad out the
window and Paul and Paul so if you throw
out Muhammad I'm gonna throw out Paul so
we both lose so we so we lose huh we
it's a double Ed
[Laughter]
sword D that's tough that's funny so man
in trouble man no disrespect but
news I mean we're in trouble it seems
yeah yeah I got it from the New
Testament you got it from the Hadith so
we're we're both like we're both losing
oh
man all right so here's here's the thing
though um my my leader isn't Paul it's
Jesus so I'm still good but you you you
you gotta follow Muhammad oh you you
need Paul without Paul you you you you
can't be a Christian oh true at all I
don't need
Paul so so you deny the new test
no I don't need Paul to be a
Christian yeah your theology rests on
Paul
your by faith oh rest on Jesus now Paul
was used by Jesus to expound on our
Theology and break things down which is
beautiful but I don't need Paul to be a
Christian I need Jesus that's all I need
right we don't and we don't worship
Muhammad so so but you but you need
Muhammad um to you know have God's
message you need Muhammad you got to
obey Allah and obey the messenger
Muhammad so M mine never says obey Jesus
and Obey Paul I just got to obey Jesus
but you you you rely your entire New
Testament is all about Paul no it's no
it's not what do you think what do you
think the the first four books of the
New Testament are that's Pauline
theology all throughout nowhere is it
has nothing to do with Paul Paul's not
there
yet correct so it has nothing to do with
Paul PA ology is all over the gospels
because they were written after Paul if
they were written after Paul if they
were written after Paul then why is Paul
why does Paul quote them like Paul
quotes Luke for
example where he quotes them twice he
quot yeah he quotes the Lord's supper
and he also quotes where uh where Jesus
is uh given a parable where he says um
like the ox should eat or something like
that yeah no Paul got that from well
Paul's Lear before the gospels Paul got
it from Luke okay he said even if he got
it from Luke he
scure the Gospel of Luke was written
after Paul's letters if the Gospel of
Luke is written after Paul's letters
then why how is Paul
quoting Luke's writings in his letters
or Luke is quoting Paul no because Paul
says it's in the scriptures and the only
scriptures that we find these phrases in
quot in is in Luke's
gospel yes you find it in Luke's gospel
but it is also possible that Luke got it
from the letters of Paul as well and so
Paul's quoting Paul can be quoting an
earlier tradition than
Luke and Luke also got it from that same
tradition so if Paul is quoting an
earlier Trad uh tradition then that
means that the earlier tradition is not
Pauline it does doesn't have Paul's you
know um influence on it
right okay it's something that Paul
takes so this means that these early
Traditions that we're finding in the
gospel are are absent of Pauline
theology okay you can assert that okay
cool so the the gospel that we have
right written by Matthew Mark Luke and
John they have nothing to do with Paul
it's all Jesus it's atonement
theology from
Jesus and from the prophets by the way
from the prophets right from the
prophets and from Jesus right because
Jesus says in Matthew from the Q from
the Q material which is even earlier
that if you don't forgive your brother
God won't forgive you so that's actually
anti-pol that's anti atonement
forgiveness is dependent on you
forgiving so that's not Christian right
well you can't be a Christian and have
unforgiveness in your heart that's the
point I agree with that so that's
actually all with Pauline you know Paul
agre he doesn't disagree with that well
but also with that look Jesus teaches in
Matthew and you said it's early in the Q
source so in Matthew Jesus
says at the Lord's Supper this is my
blood which is poured out for you for
the Forgiveness of sins
correct that that's not the Q Source
that's that's Matthew quoting Mark do
you agree well let me ask Matthew
quoting Mark do you agree that Luke and
Matthew copied Mark no I don't oh oh wow
okay um well this is a different
conversation
um yeah because because when you read
the the Greek it's it's word for word
and you when you get the manuscripts
together they're word for word copies by
like what about the parts that's not
what about those parts so it shows
that it's not a copy it's an independent
Source well there's independent material
in it but the majority of Mark is in
both Matthew and Luke like word for word
right but and there's a lot of Matthew
that's not in Mark so just because they
have just because they have similar
information because they're talking
about the same things doesn't mean that
one copied from the other well it's word
for word it's not just similar
information it's l if you read it in the
Greek it's literally word for word for
paragraphs at a time that's why and if
and if I and if I and let's see a few
others at Oval Office in the comment
section saber in the comment section
heard what you just said and said Felix
said well yeah but they're word for word
they're word for word the exact same
thing does that mean that they copied me
or did we all just hear you say that and
we're just reporting what you said well
if we have transcripts if we write
transcripts and they're EXA they have
the exact same periods the same
intonation the same everything for
paragraphs at a time that you're not
answering the question does that mean
that we all copied or are we reporting
what we heard you say I'm sorry I don't
understand it can you repeat it because
I'm not trying to get Dison after you so
you just said I'm sorry I didn't
understand it can you repeat that
there's a few people in the comments
section that just heard you say that and
now if we all wrote on a notebook and
recorded what you just said does that
mean that we copied from each other if
we recorded exactly what you said word
for word or are we just recording what
we all heard you say oh yeah if you all
copied if you all heard me and you all
wrote it down yes you're all getting it
from the original source and so that's
what eyewitness testimony is if
eyewitness is all heard and are talking
about this this event talking about what
happened it's going to be the same for
the most part there may be some slight
differences Bas based on uh you know um
perspective you know maybe some details
that somebody might add that somebody
else might not but it's not
contradictory but for the most part
it'll be the
same Mark wasn't there though Peter was
person and Luke wasn't either Peter was
yeah but you you claimed from your
analogy are you claiming that all three
of them were there in person to copy
word for word from Jesus Peter Peter is
telling Mark so Mark Peter is dictating
what Mark is writing and Luke literally
I it's he literally says that he
interviewed the
eyewitnesses so he's writing down what
the eyewitnesses told
him okay and so if they all wrote it
down and and they all have word for word
for
paragraphs how do you account for the
contradictions not just differences
contradictions there are no
contradictions but then again let's move
it on further away from the the issue
here when we look at the gospel we see
that it is absent of Paul's influence
these are the apostles here that are
writing down what Jesus said and did and
what we see here is that Jesus taught
that he was the Divine Son of God who
came to die for your
sins okay all right
um you're saying um I I I see I also see
contradictions I also see material
that's anti-a as well but I don't know
if we have time to get into that yeah I
want I wanted to clear something up too
by the way sure that to be an
is not that you had to be with Jesus in
his Earthly Ministry but it's to have
been an eyewitness of Jesus which Paul
was Paul was an eyewitness of Jesus Jes
Paul Jesus witness I'm sorry visited
Paul while he was on his road to
Damascus and is an eyewitness of his
resurrection where did you get that
criteria from the Bible okay the well
the bi the Bible okay if Paul's if if
you got that criteria from Paul though
no the Bible like okay for example
when you say that to be an apostle the
Bible says that one you have to have
been with Jesus in his Earthly Ministry
where does the bible say that acts
121 okay acts 121 Peter from the mouth
of Peter not not Paul from Peter who
actually walked with Jesus so your
criteria uh doesn't match what Peter
said Paul has his own criteria Peter has
his own criteria so
there are two different criteria is what
so one of the men so one of the men who
accompanied US during all the time that
the Lord Jesus went in and and Out Among
Us what does it say anything about that
being the the criteria for being an
apostle it's acts 1:21 therefore it is
necessary to choose one of the men who
have been with us the whole time the
Lord Jesus was living among us 122 says
beginning from John's baptism to the
time when Jesus was taken up from us for
one of these must become a witness with
us of his resurrection yeah but where
does that say anything criteria being an
apostle bro that that's they're
literally replacing Judas they're
replacing Judas as one of the 12
apostles acts one do you do you know
that the original 12 are not the only
Apostles okay what does it say there's
other Apostles other than Paul
so well Paul is an apostle Barnabas is
an apostle Apostle you know there's
other Apostles outside of the original
12 where do the disciples say that okay
well where do where does you you want to
see the disciples approve of Paul his no
calling him an apostle not approved they
can offer they offered Paul the right
hand of Fellowship but they did not say
he was an apostle wait if they offer him
the right hand of fellowship and confirm
that Jesus called him to be sent to the
uncircumcised while they are sent to the
circumcised so an apostle to the
uncircumcised or their Apostles to the
circumcised that's redefining Apostle as
just like a general missionary no
Apostle is someone who was sent out by
the Lord that's literally what an
apostle
is where are you getting that definition
from from the definition Apostle man
where are you getting that definition
from the biblical definition of apostle
look Let's uh I'm going by Jesus and his
disciples well the the the apostles
never say that you have to be with us
from the beginning in order to be an
apostle but to join the 12 because
that's what they were known as to join
the 12 that was the the criteria was
those who have been with us from John's
baptism all the way from then all the
way till now to join the 12 that's what
you you know that was a criteria an
apostle of the Lord that that's not the
criteria there that's not what he's
talking about okay I mean uh G okay
Jesus sent out the 72 right um and to
cast out demons to do all this
missionary work in the gospels Jesus
didn't call them Apostles at all and he
s them
out can you show me the verse that
you're talking about yeah and Mark um
let me find it real quick if anyone's an
apostle it will be those 72 people
because they they literally doing the
missionary work I'm finding it right now
give me one oh
um the 72 Luke 101 Luke chapter 10 Jesus
sends out 72 to do all the things that
you're saying Paul was sent out to do
and Barnabas
Jesus didn't even call them Apostles but
he gave them the power to cast out
demons wait wait hold on a second read
read the verse from read the verse 10
after this the Lord appointed 72 others
and sent them on ahead of him two by two
in every town and place where he himself
was about to go where does it say that
they're not Apostles that's not he said
he I said he did not call them Apostles
where does he deny that they're Apostles
though that's silence that's not what I
said so you're just arguing from Silence
then
they would fit the criteria of being
Apostles your the criteria you've given
but I I I gave one from the mouth of
Peter you're I think you're
getting you the only thing you gave me
was a criteria to join the 12 that's
what you gave me not give me a criteria
to be an apostle of
God okay all right so I think I I think
this is a little bit semantics but I I
don't think these are different it's
it's C you're making a category error
that's that's where the confusion is
well we're both creating right right no
no I I understand I agree we're both
creating the category
but where does it say that the Apostle
is not just a 12 but anybody who's like
a missionary or sent out well because
you have um Paul who's identified as an
apostle Barnabas who's identified as an
apostle and matter of fact hold on I
think there's actually a let's let me
put this in here
I agree they're identified I don't want
to interrupt you um well if you're
looking something up I don't want to
just keep talking over you no no go
ahead you're fine um they're identified
as Apostles by the author of Acts but
they're not identified by Peter or the
12 that's my point or Jesus they are
identified by Peter and the 12 what are
you talking about as Apostles all right
I would like to see that verse dude so
again
look man doing an argument of silence is
not going to help you here we've already
seen in the scripture Paul Barnabas and
others they're called
Apostles they are scripture says it when
we see here what you brought up in Acts
one we see the the 12 are missing one so
they're going to add another to their
company to complete the 12 you
understand that so far I understand that
okay so the 12 being part of the
12 is different from being identified as
an apostle as a whole in in in general
you understand I understand that
categorization all right so in the
Bible Paul Barnabas are accepted as
people who have been sent out by the
Lord Jesus by the disciples the
disciples literally say yes they give
him the The Fellowship of Brotherhood
and they say that he was supposed to be
sent out he was sent out by Jesus to the
uncircumcised so they affirm his
apostleship get what I'm saying I I
agree I AG every and I agree that they
affirm his ministry they affirm his
evangelism he who is not with us is not
against us that's what Jesus said I
agree with all that but they they do not
say you are one of the
Apostles at all and so you're you're
claiming that he's an apostle but that
title wasn't used at all for Paul by the
by the 12 by Jesus by James the leader
of the Jerusalem Church and the two
times that Paul goes to James and the
Jerusalem Church in Acts 15 and acts 21
to do a purification ritual not neither
of those times do they say you're a
fellow Apostle or anything like that
that's that's where the skepticism comes
from your category is is is from Luke
and Paul but it's not from Jesus or the
twel and that's that's I guess you're
saying it's an argument from Silence I I
think I would agree but your
criteria is that you believe scriptures
inspired so it all comes from the same
Source the Holy Spirit but it doesn't
come from Jesus or Paul so I don't I'm
sorry from Jesus or the apostles so I
don't know how that helps a Muslim or
even an unbeliever like how does that
that's circular reasoning my brother
it's like you're using Paul to affirm
Paul no I'm not I'm not just using Paul
as you as what did you hear me what did
you hear me reference when it came to
Paul what did you hear me reference for
that he was called an apostle in the
scriptures but and and who did I say
approved of him and was a witness of his
apostleship approv you said the
disciples approved of him okay so I'm
not just using I'm not just using Paul
I'm using Peter James and John I'm using
the Elders of the church I'm using Jesus
himself and Luke all these different
people and these different witnesses
that are approv of Paul's
apostleship where are we at here in this
conversation all right
um my my my my last point because I I
think you I think you said you had three
hours um they they affirm his ministry
which is not the same thing as affirming
his
apostleship the that it's not just the
word isn't used at all nothing that Paul
says the 13th super Apostle none of that
is described by any of the 12 or Jesus
not even the word Apostle but they do
affirm his ministry that's my
categorization from what I see yeah
you're just making stuff up so what what
what what are we doing here let let's
get to something of substance we see
that Jesus calls Paul we see that Paul
is identified as an apostle we see that
his ministry as being called to being
Apostle to the uncircumcised is approved
by
Peter James and John what are we doing
what what what what do you ha actually
have against Paul's
apostleship I I already described it it
was not it his ministry was affirmed but
they never said you are the 13th Apostle
there wasn't there's 13 there were
many Paul claims to be the 13th and no
he never claims to be the
13th he said it in his letters defending
he never said I'm the 13th Apostle what
are you talking about he said he's the
greatest among them all because he
suffered the most or he never said he's
the greatest he said he's the least
among
them he literally said I'm the least
among the dude
what okay um in his letters he says he
was the greatest among
them so he's saying he's even above the
the 12 in his letters in Corinthians or
was it Galatians he said what they are
what they are means nothing to me like
he watch this hold on hold on here we
go 1 Corinthians chapter 15 start at
verse three for I delivered to you as of
first importance what I also received
that Christ died for our sins in
accordance with the scriptures oh so
Paul didn't make this up okay that he
was buried that he was raised on the
third day in accordance with the
scriptures and that he appeared to
sephus and then to the
12 you see how there's a category the 12
then he appeared to more than 500
Brothers at one time most of whom are
still alive though some have fallen
asleep then he appeared to James then to
all the
apostles so you have the 12 and then you
have the rest of the
Apostles using using Paul's words and
then hold on and then last of all as one
untimely born he appeared also to me for
I am the least of the Apostles unworthy
to be called an apostle because I
persecuted the Church of God but by the
grace of God I am what I am and his
grace toward me was not in vain on the
contrary I worked harder than any of
them though it was not I but the grace
of God that was that was with me whether
then it was I or they so we preached and
so you believed what a beautiful
powerful message by the least of the
Apostles where where are you getting it
from that Paul claimed to be the
greatest among them like that's a
literal lie on what he
says
okay so look bro I guess I made it
up uh I didn't come prepared with that
one I I I know I found it but if I find
it at another live stream I I'll share
it but you're welcome to come back again
Felix I enjoyed you man all right I
enjoyed it too very polite cool brother
take care take care all right guys
that's it for me man um hope you guys
enjoyed it
today um you know you know what are you
gonna do man what are you gonna do at
least at least you can have fun try to
have fun in these conversations